hi everyone alex gent here so in the
last three videos we've been looking at
staff spinning
and today i'm going to be talking about
spinning and whether it's got any place
when it comes to martial application
the short answer is both yes and no
[Music]
so firstly it's not always clear to know
what's applicable and what's not
a better question to ask is what's the
context and
why do you do certain movements now when
we're talking about staff spinning
we're generally talking about these type
of figure eight spins
side to side and rotating from the
middle now this in itself
isn't very martial for several reasons
holding the staff in one hand isn't
necessarily an issue
but the hand placement does make a
difference as to whether it's marshall
or not
if for example i'm in this position and
i'm spinning from the center of the
staff
oh let's ignore footwork for the time
being and i was doing this type of
movement
doesn't matter how much i try and spin
it and generate power
it's not really that powerful because
it's actually dividing
the two ends and the powers the power
that i can potentially generate
is split in two whereas
if i actually offset the grip i'm
creating more of a leverage
to the other end which creates more
force and more power
which from a marshall aspect is more
applicable
so if i was in the same position again
not using footwork
and i was doing the same type of figure
eight movement as this
but actually offset towards the top of
the staff
i can generate much more power
even if i'm not using the other hand
just that sweep down
you can generate a lot of power into
that if we then start introducing
footwork into it
it then starts to take more of a martial
form the other factor to consider is the
angles on the plane of
the strike so this same movement shown
from this side
side profile if i was just doing it like
this
it kind of looks the same but i'm not
really getting that much power out of it
and i'm going down in a in this type of
angle so i'm showing you front
i'm sweeping down like this which that
isn't very martial
i'm just twirling the sticker out
even if i try and put a bit more effort
into it
it's not actually becoming a strike i'm
just moving it from side to side
and it's not really doing that much i
was thinking about where i was striking
what i want to be doing is going more at
an angle like this rather than a shallow
angle
so as i step forward i want that
to be coming round and going more
across rather than raising it up and
coming down like this
i need it to be more striking across
like this going back and striking across
the other way as well now this kind of
contradicts
with some of the previous videos where
i've talked about trying to keep
the planes nice and tight which is more
like this but again it's the context
are we stop spinning or are we actually
looking at it as being a strike
so how does spinning actually help us
well when it comes to plane control
i think it plays an important part if
for example we use this strike as an
example
if i'm striking across the face there if
it was
missing for example i might take it wide
and control it here and the same when
i'm going back
and it takes this quite wide angle
if i was for example to strike them and
if you if you actually hit things this
is why i think it's important to
actually get things so you actually get
that
feeling of actually hitting and then
recovering afterwards if you're able to
follow through it's okay if it kind of
ricochets
and then comes down that's where it
would take that shallow angle
again going back if i'm striking here
and then it drops down
you'd have that angle but it's all about
the intention
you need to have that feeling of wanting
to go across
and that's the angle that you need to be
taking if for example you're hitting
something and it actually
hits and then drops you still need to be
able to recover at that point
so i demonstrated that with the 13th joe
sabori however we can also
apply various spinning movements
in martial application when holding the
center of the job providing we're also
in contact with the back end of the jaw
as well and this can be seen
with the hasso movements
so if we were to look at hasso front on
the same thing applies
if this is a deflection as i make
contact here i want to make sure that
there is
this pressure there and i'm not just
laying it drop down like this
as i said before if i'm just doing this
it's just a twirling movement and it's
got no intention
what i want to be doing is actually
visualizing that i'm making contact here
and as this contact
goes across that's where i'm deflecting
whether it's a thrust whatever it might
be
it's actually going there and it's going
to cross
the line what i don't want to do is just
let it
drop down like this
however again same thing if there's
actually contact
at this point here and there's a
deflection it might be the case that if
you're actually making contact and
hitting something
you might drop down into that position
and then it's taking more of a shallow
angle and changing
trajectory so that's where the spinning
i suppose um becomes useful because
you're understanding the different
planes
and you have control in different angle
from different angles
now although rotating from the center
isn't very good for striking it is much
quicker which is good for positioning
so using this hasso movement
i could do the same movement but instead
of taking it up
i could actually just change my position
so i'm in a thrusting position from the
other side
and that can be done quite quickly you
can use the spinning movement to change
between low to high
thrusting positions or change directions
so to sum up context is key even if
there isn't a martial application
movement might offer flexibility a
better understanding of plane control
or maybe you just enjoy doing it either
way understanding why you do a certain
movement
will give you a better outcome anyway
that's it for this video
i hope you enjoyed this series on staff
spinning
if you've got any questions leave them
in the comments below and until next
time take care and i'll see you soon